his name is Slater listen and unless we
stop him he's gonna kill Oliver and his
entire family not yet good hey youtubers
is Charlie and this week on arrow Slade
Wilson returned to fulfill a promise he
made to Oliver but it's really just the
beginning this is actually the first
episode in a line of the next four
episodes that comprises of villains arc
it's also the beginning of Season 2's
endgame meaning every episode until the
finale we'll take this Oliver vs. Slade
storyline to new levels next week is a
break so there won't be an episode but I
will be doing a predictions video be
sure to subscribe to get it if you're
finding me for the first time since
there were so many WTF moments in the
episode let's do our top 5 and then I'll
do some of my favorite quotes and then
my review I've also got some details
about grant gustin's cameo that's coming
later this season so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet but here we go number 5 businessman
Slade meets Oliver's family
the main conceit here is that Slade was
planting bugs all over Oliver's house
but I loved listening to businessman
Slade talking to Moira as if he were
just a totally normal person a totally
normal person running on mirakuru and
leading a small army of supervillains to
destroy her family more to his campaign
contribution though I think he's going
to embed himself in Queen industries via
Summer Glau who's still part of the
story even though he lied about not
having a daughter I think she's working
with him she may not know who he really
is though to be clear about his children
ravager and Jericho Oliver mentioned
Jericho in a previous episode so either
Slade just thinks they're dead or
they're emotionally dead to him so he
could have just been making a metaphor
number 4 team arrow rolls into battle
there were a lot of other teasers in the
rollout montage like Roy with a bow but
when the party so to speak started it
was like being ringside at a Muhammad
Ali fight that's why my favorite lines
of dialogue from the episode came right
then Oliver's what would you like to do
now mr. Wilson and Slade's reply I hate
to break up the party the big reveal
from that though was finding out what
the actual promise was and Slade's a lie
that took Diggle out number three all
hell breaks loose on the freighter I'm
considering a lot of the boat scenes to
be part of this starting the moments
late all of her was responsible for
shadows death they rebuilt the whole
deck of the boat to shoot the action
scene and it looked glorious just a hail
of bullets and people jumping overboard
my favorite stunt hands down was Slade
reaching over and grabbing all of our
midair as he was jumping over the side
and just yanking him back on I know a
little bit about how stunts are done so
I knew they were using wires but it
still looks so amazing and it only got
crazier when Slade took control of the
boat number two Oliver and Slade put on
the hood in the mask for the first time
this is like the birth of their personas
the arrow and Deathstroke if you
remember the Australian rum they drank
they actually toasts it again
before the fight just like they did at
the Queen's House in retrospect both
times seemed like they were toasting
their impending doom there were some
funny moments that followed like Oliver
missing that Lord of the Rings signal
fire shot but really the best one was
Slade calling him a brother I think that
Oliver's going to try really hard to
redeem Slade by the end of the season
even though they're totally gonna spend
the next four episodes trying to kill
each other and my number one moment
Slade without his eyepatch watching
Oliver's mansion the first thing that
really grabs you is his eyeless socket
it's just haunting I think it's meant to
visually show the hole he has inside his
soul right now like punishing Oliver
will replace what he's lost
you know both shadow and the eye that to
me was bigger than Slade just peeping on
the Queen's that really just implies
that he's going to use the surveillance
to catch them with their pants down so
to speak here a couple of my favorite
bonus moments though there were a bunch
Rowan Slade's handshake of the century
Oliver's murder dream of shado Oliver's
training montage in the island you know
just running while shooting and doing
something that looked very similar to
salmon ladders and I already said a few
my favorite quotes but here a few more
lucky for me before all this I had a lot
of practice
Slade calling Sarah blondie I'm
fortunate to have your entire family
here I have allies too my favorite quote
hands down though was Felicity's looks
like Oliver butt-dialed us she didn't
have much of a presence in the episode
but they did give her one of the best
quotes my other favorite was Slade's
promise though you cannot die until you
have known complete despair as I have
overall I give the episode a solid a but
it's really just the appetizer to the
main course that is the next four
episodes
that's what arrow has done so well this
season is build the stories in such a
way that they all kind of inform these
final episodes this final arc
we should all go back and re-watch
season 1 at 2:00 right now because think
of how the context of those stories
changed now that we know what's really
been going on since Oliver came back
Slade has been planning this revenge the
whole time the episode itself really did
feel like a sequel to season ones The
Odyssey remember that episode set up
shado storyline and mirrored a lot of
moments with Yau and Billy wintergreen
high-fives to the production team though
seriously they revoked the entire deck
for a major action scene and it just
looked amazing Marc Guggenheim was
behind it and he also had a big teaser
this morning about episode 20 he was
waiting for a special announcement to
reveal what's happening but it's
basically Grant Gustin coming back to
guest star as the flash I'm predicting
that he'll come out of his coma but he
might not have the red suit yet he will
have his superpowers though I am
thinking he will be key to defeating
Slade otherwise why would they bring him
back we only know the titles of episodes
up to 18 and they're gonna be 23 total
this season so there's still so much
that it's left to happen I cannot wait
to see it it is so much fun
be sure to subscribe to get all my arrow
and flash stuff I'll be doing another
flash bonus video this week and I'll be
doing a Q&A video so feel free to ask me
any question you want about the episode
or the rest of the season right now
click here to learn all about arrow
season 3 in here to get that Q&A video
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives
you